have you bought all your fourth of july
staples yet well if not everything else
this year it's going to cost you more
experts say it is the largest single
year jump in the cost of a cookout since
2012. paul gurkey gives us a look
the average cost of an independence day
cookout this year might make carnivores
clench
the price of ground beef has risen 36
percent in the last year boneless
skinless chicken breasts and center cut
pork chops more than 30 percent you'll
be pouring out more for sides too pork
and beans are 33 percent pricier
lemonade 22 percent potato salad 19
burger buns 16 percent
even desserts can't escape inflation's
wrath a half gallon of vanilla ice cream
and a 13 ounce bag of cookies together
will set you back nearly 9 50 on average
but not everything is more expensive
than it was in 2021 strawberries are 16
percent cheaper potato chips four sliced
cheese 13. all together these dozen
staples of a cookout cost the average
american 59.50 last year this
independence day 69-68
so we've got to savor each bite 17
percent more